let's talk about this very controversial
golf tournament that took place over the
weekend at donald trump's bedminster
golf club this is part of the live golf
tour liv
this is controversial because it is
backed by
saudi arabia the saudi royal family some
of the controversy relates to
left-handed golfer phil mickelson who
has accepted a bunch of money to be a
sort of premier player on the live golf
tour and much controversy about listen
these are human rights abusers these are
murderers this is an absolutely brutal
regime should they really be welcomed
with open arms at american golf clubs
should phil mickelson be accepting money
should trump be playing give me a break
guys
and donald trump was confronted about
this this is and by the way
tickets
selling for as little as a dollar
very low levels of interest in attending
this thing and it was mostly trump tools
there was a chant of four more years
that broke out at the event a chant of
let's go brandon that broke out
all this stuff so very very thin crowds
trump uh gets confronted about listen
these the saudis like they did 9 11.
what about the criticism that this is an
insult to the families of the victims of
9 11 and trump's response is to go full
conspiracy nut and say no one's gotten
to the bottom of 9 11.
what
yes we have
check this out
you're so closely associated with the
city of new york you of all people
understand the passion surrounding 9 11.
what do you say to those family members
who posted protested earlier this week
and we'll be doing so again on friday
well nobody's gotten to the bottom of 9
11 unfortunately and they should have as
to the maniacs that did that horrible
thing to our city to our country to the
world so nobody's really been there but
i can tell you that
there are a lot of really great people
that are out here today and we're going
to have a lot of fun and we're going to
celebrate and money's going to charity a
lot of money's going to charity and
really the best players in the world
many of the best players in the world
and soon you'll probably have all of
them so quite a word salad there and i
would any time any any any time trump
says that money is going to charity i
would follow up to see if that's
actually the case
but
what does it mean that we haven't gotten
to the bottom of 911 and interestingly
before it became politically
inconvenient for trump because he's just
so enamored with the saudis trump used
to say it was the saudis who did 9 11
period like here is donald trump in 2016
in an interview on fox news he doesn't
mince words at all right now that front
and center with so many people i'm
getting on the radio yesterday and today
is the 28 pages that were taken out of
the 911 report uh saudi arabia evidently
there's references saudi arabia you have
a democratic senator now retired senator
graham who says it's time for the public
to see him does donald trump believe
it's time for us to see these 28 pages
i do i think we should have seen it a
long time ago
you know i think i know what it's going
to say it's going to be very
very profound having to do with saudi
arabia and saudi arabia's role on the
world trade center and the attack and
that's very serious stuff and you know
again i've said it for a long time we
attacked iraq and frankly by attacking
iraq they were not the ones that knocked
down the world trade center right saying
that for a long time let's see what the
papers say that's absolutely right trump
didn't used to hesitate but here's what
it's really about this is from the
interview over the weekend i've known
these people for a long time in saudi
arabia and they've been friends of mine
for a long time
they've invested in many american
companies they own big percentages of
many many american companies and frankly
what they're doing for golf is so great
what they're doing for the players is so
great the salaries are going to go way
up
the pga was not loved by a lot of the
players as you know for a long time so
there it is that's what it's really
about it's about business that's
fundamentally what it is
now one more note on this our friends
the good liars davrum and jason they
were at the live golf tournament and
they really did a good one with phil
mickelson this has gone giga viral
millions and millions of views
as phil mickelson was getting ready to
hit his uh his golf ball
our friend jason gave him some
interesting words of encouragement
listen to this all right last hour phil
mickelson teed off here at the 16th hole
just behind me here's what happened
[Music]
do it for the saudi royal family
okay so that that was very distracting
to phil to phil mickelson and he ended
up having to rethink that shot so we've
never gotten to the bottom of 9 11.
that's really the problem when we talk
about the saudis says donald trump now
very different tune to 2016 and very
different tune to points prior so uh
that's that and trump going full
conspiracy if you're curious about some
of these clips and you're only listening
today make sure to check out the david
pakman show instagram
david pakman show
i do what i can
when it comes to climate change because
this is one of the most important issues
of our time if we don't have a planet
it's hard to do much about women's
rights or campaign finance or whatever
and i do whatever i can at the
individual level bearing in mind that
corporations also have to change a lot
to reduce my climate footprint this
includes being aware of how far is my
food coming from or how much trash am i
generating these types of things and
this is why our sponsor rent is so
important ren is a chartered public
benefit company and they unlock the
collective action of individuals against
climate change and ren is a very simple
and effective way to make a difference
on climate rent is a website where you
calculate your carbon footprint
personally you answer a few questions
about your lifestyle wren will then tell
you what your carbon footprint is and
let you offset it
by funding a diverse mix of carbon
reduction projects like tree planting
mineral weathering
rainforest protection once you sign up
to make a monthly contribution to offset
your carbon footprint you'll get monthly
updates from the projects you support
and you'll get to see
where is your money going you'll see
photos you'll get details it will take a
lot to end the climate crisis but you
can start offsetting your carbon
footprint today and ren will cover the
first month of your subscription for
free when you sign up at ren dot co
slash david the link is down below